et maintenant j'accueille mon cdd il est
toujours en cdd tom villa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
savatier super c'est marrant je ne sais
pas pourquoi mais je sens que ce soir ça
peut déraper là on a un acteur un
chanteur un juge l'ex star dû x ça
commence comme un cluedo sait pas qui va
finir avec le chandelier et où va finir
le chandelier mais ça demain
c'est le prochain invité il connaît
tellement bien les terroristes même
quand un gamin fait une bombe à la
piscine il se méfie c'est marc trévidic
là qu'il a été juge antiterroriste voilà
parce que tous les terroristes
tristement connus se sont assis un jour
en face de marc trévidic un peu comme
michel drucker avec vivement dimanche
confirme enfin pour ce qui reste bien
entendu parce que vous le rappeler
terroristes et des carrières très courte
t'as pas le temps de cotiser pour ta
retrait de toute façon il n'y a pas de
retraite voilà et vous avez dit à propos
des terroristes il y en a 5 6 qui
m'inquiète j'espère qu'ils sont pas
encore sortis de prison est-ce que vous
pouvez être plus précis parce que 5,6
c'est pas la même chose marx et voilà et
là il vient pour un livre voilà qui
s'appelle le magasin jaune et sa
retraite l'histoire d'un lieu où joie et
désespoir se succèdent voilà j'aurais pu
l'appeler le parti socialiste mais après
ça c'est comme vous voulez et on pense
maintenant à notre qui est au top
[Musique]
marc trévidic re bonsoir
alors je suis président du tgi de lille
mais surtout vous êtes l'ancien juge du
pôle antiterroriste de paris alors on
était content en fait de pas trop vous
voir à la télé ces derniers temps parce
que ça veut dire qui avait pas eu
d'attentât donc voilà les terroristes
ont compris que faire l'amour avec des
vierges même au paradis c'est est moins
sympa que des filles expérimentées en
fait donc ils ont essayé expérimenté ça
aussi un tracas alors la police c est
meilleur ou les terroristes sont moins
bons en ce moment mais les terroristes
et prennent des bon ben ouais donc on
leur fait la guerre et ils ont d'autres
choses à faire que de s'occuper de la
métropole ouais ça mais toi tu es peau
au contre le taureau
parcours de début
ensuite terroriste alors les gens les
gens oublient un peu d'éclat pas
d'attentats évidemment la vie recommence
normalement les gens on boire des verres
en terrasse un temps dans le corps n'y a
pas écrit qu'il est interdit de boire
des verres en terrasse c'est précisé
quand même alors j'ai déclaré juge
antiterroriste a été un travail addictif
et excitant il faut aussi reconnaître
que ça nous donne une certaine
importance c'est sûr qu'à côté des
affaires familiales voilà une différence
c'est les divorces à lille ah oui c'est
moins porteur j'allais dire pour la gare
ya plus de divorcer que deux terroristes
oui heureusement mondiale alors on fait
quoi un lille le soir par coucher avec
sa soeur
je n'ai pas de soeur n'avait pas de
sauvegarde baj on n'écrit pas non mais
on a en parlé oui mais là si c'est dur
la vie est là on voit votre logement de
fonction là c'est quand même heure les
autres est ce que c'est vrai marque que
vous aviez commencé à creuser un tunnel
dans l'espoir de vous évader à paris
c'était trop loin quand même 200 km
cette radio l'exil à ces durées quand
même mais ça ça n'a qu'un temps ça
loin de chez eux
[Musique]
la bonne nouvelle c'est que c'est
bientôt fini vous allez prendre la tête
d'une chambre un versailles si conseil
supérieur de la magistrature dit ok mais
c'est plus un processus d'abattage à sa
chambre à djawad
michon mont royal
non mais ça peut arriver oui oui bien
sûr il faut que jamais il faut jamais
vendre la peau de l'ours avant qu'il
soit tué en tout cas j'espère qu'ils
auront compris que j'ai une famille qui
l'attend une petite chienne aussi qui
n'auraient pas les formidables moi je me
disais ok par chez nous
parmi nous vous allez retrouver votre
femme trois enfants et lilou donc le
fameux cavalier king charles donc vous
avez sur votre portable très très beau
ce chien abbas est difficile de la
laisser le lundi matin pour partir toute
la semaine à lille pouvait passer des
heures à la regarder oui c'est triste je
sentais pas capable de ça avant de me
poser quelque part et regarder vie vous
areva estime première sans rien faire
maintenant oui j'arrive là on la regarde
on joue et j'espère jouer à kampala
qu'un petit bout de bois vous donne un
petit boulot là là il ya un petit plus
par exemple l'enjeu final sur les
clichés
ça vous détend
alors quand vous pensez à ça pour ses
nuits au divorce et au terrorisme alors
voilà en regardant lille ou de petites
chaînes vous pensez à vos livres et vous
êtes ici ce soir derrière marc trévidic
pour votre deuxième roman publié chez
lattès ça s'appelle le magasin jaune
vous dit quand j'ai écrit mon premier
essai sur le terrorisme personnes
n'écrivez dessus mais aujourd'hui on ne
voit là tout le monde le fait regarder
le nombre de bouquins énorme écrit sur
le terrorisme dont je comprends vous
ayez arrêté ah oui c'est ça une
explosion littéralement si l'on peut
dire
mais en même temps pas vous passer au
roman vous parlez de la crise de 29 de
la guerre de 40 de l'occupation par les
nazis donc oui mais un magasin de jouets
dans tout ça c'est à dire c'est aussi
l'espoir un endroit féerique qui
traverse une période difficile au taf et
voilà le livre s'appelle le magasin
jaune alors c'est l'histoire d'un mec
qui achètent un magasin de jouets qui
leur pend mimosas couleurs mimosas très
brillant unsa dans cette période noire
il ya ce magasin et c'était un peu comme
dans les séries ce qu'on appelle la
reine c'est à dire que c'est l'endroit à
travers lequel on voit l'histoire du
monde veuve de ce point de vue là se
fasse à pigalle donc entre les deux
guerres puis ensuite chaze
l'occupation tout surtout l'occupation
et ici aussi le regard des enfants qui
est intéressant parce que c'est comment
les enfants vivent une période noire
comme ça comment ils réagissent font
comme les adultes c'est un copie les
adultes comme on peut jouer avec des
petits soldats ou est ce que il essaie
d'être un peu en dehors de tout ça alors
la mère du héros gustave et est morte en
couches et vous dites il a tué sa mère
peut-il rendre une femme heureuse oui
c'est le problème de la personne qui tue
pas 10 dès le départ parce qu'il est
venu au monde en tuant la personne qu'il
donne la vie c'est quelque chose de très
complexe psychologique mans et ça peut
marquer un individu sur place et quatre
ce personnage à lui son père est mort ça
mais un an
le livre passe l'époque en revue donc on
voit le 6 février 34 donc talent c'est
l'époque des manifestations des
manifestations un peu fascisante
amharique les croix de feu voilà il
avait différents des différents
groupuscules d'extrême droite qui qui se
féliciter de la montée de l'extrême
droite en allemagne donc c'est un peu
précurseur de ce qui va nous arriver
derrière c'est une violence terrible ce
6 février 34 les camelots du roi
couper les jarrets des chevaux de la
garde républicaine avec des rasoirs
tandis que la société actuelle est
violente je crois qu'il suffit regarder
quelques années avant ça n'a rien à voir
et il est question d'un mariage qui bat
de l aile
gustave à un moment n'aime plus trop sa
famille retourne voir manon la
prostituée qui l'a un peu déniaisé au
départ et sa femme ballantyne se met à
rêver du docteur ambroise qui le beau
gosse du quartier quoi ce problème
contre gus table
valentine sa femme est-ce que c'est
autobiographique non moins chez nous non
mais sérieux vous êtes séparé de votre
femme depuis plusieurs années vous êtes
à lille ah oui alors c'est le test
absolue on s'interroge je comprends que
faisait inquiet oui mais c'est le test
absolue en fait elle me manque beaucoup
et du manque beaucoup ouais sera peut
être la mère soutient mon père c'est
mieux sans elle voit pas du tout le cas
alors il est question de femme qui
couche avec les allemands oui bien sûr
parce que les prostituées c'est normal
qu'elle couche est également y en a qui
couchent et gratuitement avec les
animaux peut être pires ans avait fait
dire chercher un peu sur l'époque
d'abord les prostituées ont été
mobilisés les allemands créer des tout
de suite un service pour ça pour 6 des
troupes allemandes à paris et donc on
crée des bordels pour leurs troupes donc
la plupart des prostituées officiels ont
été mobilisés pour les trous officiers
ou soldats il ya eu quelques clandestine
prostituées et essayer de travailler
c'était illégal et puis après il ya
effectivement les amatrices celles qui
sont pas prostituée qu'on parlait par le
soldat allemand c'est l'élu berckois de
l'épaule ils n'ont pas tout à fait tout
à fait droit et voilà et ça c'est la
dernière catégorie julien en même temps
que m'avait répondu arletty au type qui
l'interrogeaient à la fin de la guerre
parce qu'elle était tombée amoureuse
d'un officier allemand elle leur avait
répondu fallait pas les laisser rentrer
4 cette phrase tu as bu l'eau ce n'est
pas de moi que j'avais trouvé dans un
livre mais c'est un officier allemand
qui s'assoit à côté d'une belle
parisienne et qui lui dit john parisse
et lui répond
c'est très beau et encore plus de reggae
de venir quand vous étiez pas là
la morale de l'histoire
c'est le bonheur est fragile comme une
poupée de porcelaine ouais c'est beau
c'est juste vrai en plus c'est tout à
fait ça il faut faire il faut préserver
son bonheur justement oman bonheur ça
dure fallas pas votre premier roman à
l'âme c'était bien vendu oui très bien
mais vous ne voulez pas devenir un
écrivain professionnel voulais que ça
reste un hobby j'ai un métier en fait
c'est vrai
mais j'avoue que j'espère qu'ils vont
vous remettez l'antiterrorisme ça je
sais pas c'est pas vrai que j'ai aussi
mes nouvelles
[Musique]
là je peux vous dire c'est le message
est passé il adore cette émission sont
une-deux avec brigitte comme ça lors
quand vous avez commencé comme juge
d'instruction
vous vous en faisait une idée
extrêmement romantique c'est à vous
pensiez vous allez être zorro quoi c'est
sympa et puis en fait malheureusement la
réalité j'ai commencé à péronne en
picardie
non mais c'est vrai la vie boulot c'est
qu'en fait on est tout seul n'y a pas de
blé oui ils ont compliqué les affaires
sont horribles quoi sont pas tous aussi
grandiose qu'on imagine
vous vouliez être un héros et finalement
vous avez pu réaliser un petit peu de
votre rêve puisque vous êtes devenu le
héros d'une bd
consacrée à l'antiterrorisme qui
s'appelle compte à rebours est quand
même une ressemblance est destiné je
crois qu'il a fait
mais bien donc j'ai participé sûr mais
ça y est vous êtes un héros maintenant
non non non aux sentiments n'ont
d'ailleurs le juge parce que ce sera une
série de trois bd le linge fait des
erreurs je tiens à ce que cela soit
réaliste quand même et pas du tout
donner une image idyllique quelque chose
qu'il n'est pas un bravo allemands
marquent c'est le juge antiterroriste
que je vais interviewer un verre une
interview ils ne comprennent rien
[Musique]
qu'est ce que nous n'avons pas compris à
propos des salafistes même quand il
sourit nous aiment pas dac qu'est ce que
nous n'avons pas compris à propos de
l'arabie saoudite
ils font semblant de nous aimer qu'est
ce que nous n'avons pas compris à propos
de l'iran les iraniens la plupart font
semblant ne pas nous aimer d'accord
qu'est ce que nous n'avons pas compris à
propos de l'état islamique
c'est tellement laid que ça pouvait
arriver
qu'est ce que n'ont pas compris à propos
de l'idéologie de dèche que la plupart
des membres de dèche n'ont pas compris
leur propre idéologie
qu'est ce que n'ont pas compris à propos
de l'origine de dèche une fée s'est
penchée sur le berceau et que c'était
bachar el-assad a way mauvais c'est un
état peut-être bercé un peu trop près du
mur aussi est ce que n'a pas compris à
propos de l'islam qu'il n'y a pas un
islam et plusieurs
caisses que nous n'avons pas compris à
propos du retour des jihadistes
ça s'en va et ça revient c'est normal
quand martyrs reviennent pas qu'ils
aient fait de tous petits effets de
toute l'algérie avec 2-1
qu'est ce que n'a pas compris à propos
de ben laden c'est un mec plus cool que
al bagdadi ouais ouais c'est dire c'est
dire qu'est ce que n'a pas compris à
propos du 11 septembre
tous s'en vont les avions
ils s'en vont d'eux n'a pas compris à
propos des services secrets français qui
font tout pour qu'on comprenne pas ce
qu'ils font ouais voilà c'est un peu
près le seul but du jeu c'est sacré
qu'est-ce qu'ils n'ont pas compris à
propos des lois antiterroristes c'est
comme les lapins ils n'arrêtent pas d'en
faire
donc voilà
bien nuit en l'occurrence est finalement
qu'est-ce qu'il n'y avait pas compris à
propos des juges antiterroristes qu'il
faut qu'il compose avec toutes les
incompréhensions convient de citer un
bien
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu